there are only two kinds of people in
this world those who consume illegal
drugs and those who know someone who
does now I'm not here to critique or
judge people who consume drugs I have
nothing against the drugs themselves my
aim in giving this talk however is to
pull down the curtain so you can see
what is perhaps not obvious so do you
all know what is actually going on
before illegal drugs get into the u.s. I
care deeply about this issue because I
was born and raised in the north of
Mexico my home town is some 200 miles
south of Texas and he just tweeted
placing which as a kid I would bike and
skate around with my friends and people
exercised in the streets safely but now
everyone is living in constant fear
children are not allowed to play outside
and literally everyone I know could
stand before you today and share a
horrific story of how the drug trade
violence has damaged their lives I have
seen this other side and I have to kept
quiet for way too long
I have lacked the courage to speak and I
have feared being the outlier from
breaking my silence today because people
need to hear this especially here in the
US you know the u.s. is the largest
market for illegal drugs with only 5% of
the world's population it consumes over
30 percent of the global demand and
what's really interesting is that the
vast majority of the millions and
millions of users are using the drugs
for recreational purposes but only by
buying they are creating a demand and
wherever there is demand there will be
supply and this supply is costing human
lives let me let's try this for you
let's say you are a user and you feel
like getting high tonight or this
weekend so you would contact your
trusted dealer and engage in a business
transaction with him or her all you see
is a victimless crime so you get high
and no big deal but what you don't see
is that for any dealer to be able to
sell to you they need to be working with
one of the cartels and before cartels
supply to their dealers dealers they
either produced the drugs in Mexico or
imported them from Asia or South America
and cross them to the US by land air or
sea and at every step of the chain
there's bloodshed why is this the case
well because this is the most lucrative
of all criminal activities as a result
it attracts the worst criminals to it
and criminals compete by force so this
is effectively a business in which the
most violent player wins and what are
they fighting over well territories
highways ports border crossings
political influence and so on
because the real money to this business
is not in producing drugs but in getting
them from the source to the end consumer
here in the US and to do that
successfully cartels need to control
their traffic routes every step of the
way and to prevent smaller criminal
groups from growing and eventually
competing with them they also set out to
control the smaller criminal activities
like human trafficking kidnapping piracy
extortion and even prostitution to
protect their huge profits they are
killing not only the people involved in
the business but also journalists law
enforcers and innocents who refuse to
cooperate
they even sometimes engage in mass
killings of civilians just to instigate
fear in a town in the span of this hour
of talks three people are getting killed
just in Mexico this is 60 lives every
single day many of them are innocent men
women and children the official death
toll since 2007 stands at 160,000 this
number is larger than that of the Iraq
and Afghanistan wars combined
this is the bloodiest conflict in North
America
since the American Civil War one morning
back in the spring of 2010 I found out
that for very close members of my family
had been kidnapped by one of the cartels
long hours of fear and suffering turn
into days they Stern in two weeks we
didn't know what was going on and we
still don't because we never saw them
again the narcos disappear them breaking
my family apart
now by show of hands who here believes
in making the world a better place
to our daily actions I believe most
people do actually in the u.s. every day
is more common to hear about people
becoming vegetarian to save animals
people are buying cruelty-free cosmetics
Fairtrade coffee
conflict-free diamonds and I deeply
admire how this heightened awareness
about supply chains is growing but
unfortunately we haven't yet picked up
in the worst of them when there is
killing not animals but human lives
because Americans are spending around
150 billion dollars on illegal drugs
every year an amount that is slightly
higher than what the US federal
government spends on education in five
times larger than what the US federal
government spends on law enforcement so
you can see why this problem is so huge
and thanks to a very convenient
geographic location Mexican cartels
control over 70% of the US market the
truth is that with an incentive of this
magnitude no government action in the US
or Mexico will ever be enough to
mitigate the violence around three years
ago Maddie a hard-working lower-class
woman who worked with me for over six
years
realized that one of the cartels was
recruiting young boys from her
neighborhood by force being the mother
of a 14-year old boy
Matty panicked so she took her whole
family and they walk away they run away
for several months they leave that a
very remote and uncomfortable shelter so
as soon as they hear that their
neighborhood was relatively safe again
the family returned home on the second
night from their return a group of armed
men enter their house and killed her boy
in front of her and her whole family
just in retaliation
I completely understand if some of you
are thinking how come the Mexican
government is not doing anything about
this
it is a Mexicans fault that they have
such a corrupt government and weak
institutions and you know what that's
fair I accept I will responsibility and
we are doing something about it but the
pool is way too strong how are we
supposed to fight against those hundreds
of billions of dollars in automatic guns
the cartels
just buy their way around Mexico and
those who don't take their money get
killed the fact we can't work away from
that every time we buy illegal drugs we
approve required and in some device
discriminant organizations we approve
reward and incentivize the narcos so I
stand before you today because I
desperately need your help and because I
know that each one of us here to bring
about a huge change think about these
recreational users spend between two
hundred and two thousand dollars on
illegal drugs every month just to give
you a glimpse of what this money buys
for the cartels with $200 they can get
eight thousand new rounds of ammunition
five hundred dollars a brand-new ak-47
rifle seven hundred dollars pays the
monthly cost of a full-time employee
under that squad what if instead you or
someone close to you stopped buying
illegal drugs you would single-handedly
help prevent several kidnappings
extortions or worse so if you're not the
user I ask you to please have this
conversation with your friends with your
families and if you are one please think
twice before you buy again consider
alcohol or legal weed instead just don't
lie to yourself because now you know
where your money would find its way to
eventually if we succeed my family
people in my hometown and all over Latin
America would start feeling safe again
our children will go back to playing
outside thank
you